[Music]
looks like a picture for a gender
studies class
the teacher comes in puts a cake on
table say all right so let's talk about
the first layer
the first layer is where white folks
live second layer is where oppression
really happens as the white layer
compresses down
on the minorities and the females hey
new york community college
come to us and it's just this picture
there's seven of you here
you guys have to decide together who's
the one person guys here's the thing we
could each leave with like 150
no no of course the communists had to
show up let's redistribute the wealth
so you guys ready yes yes just judging
by the hair color in this video i guess
you this is gonna be like
who's the most impressed or like um
who's head it the worst and then you
should get the video that's what it
looks like
so first round all the white people are
out yeah they better be out
and the white people should vote
themselves out just to make sure that
they recognize that they're living on
the top layer
which is where the most amount of
oppression happens so what's everybody's
sign
what does that have to do with
everything i want to know bank balances
i want to know personal
stories uh rehearsal stories so i'm
black in america
so she sucks that's why i deserve a
thousand dollars i'm an immigrant
oh i don't think i want to make it bro
this is the definition of of victim
olympics
let's see this this is the most
appropriate time to use that term
everyone who's now black leaves as a
form of reparation
let's try to get through this daniel i
gotta get
back on your belly field i gotta get
through this i gotta get through this
i gotta gotta get three days give me
your 30 second pitch why you deserve a
thousand dollars
cry a little bit you are especially
vocal
what do you got i spend every single day
trying to save the world i work on
issues of climate change i am a good
person
and i need new tires but tires is not
good
it's not ecological if you have a car
you you're you're burning gas
okay here we go i haven't been working
since april this would be my third
surgery
within a year since my my initial
accident like seriously my bank account
is literally like negative 300 right now
i'm 19 years old i'm a full-time student
money would
really freaking help i just bailed out
my parents 10 grand and that was
actually what i was supposed to use for
my daughter's college fund
sorry what if we helped you by
connecting you to a mentor that we know
i don't think i could do it bro i need
money for tires but yo you and your
single daughter plus your parents who
just came out of prison
i could connect you to a mentor damn
these people are so slimy
but that's just it could have been 100
bucks they will act the same
as soon as you put a goal people act
even the people that are most like man
they're going to start acting like
they want that because they set a goal
it's crazy it's wow that this girl's
like i'm a good person
climate change this girl's like man i
got my daughter i'm a full-time student
not move next damn good people don't
need to say that they're good people
duh bruh crunchy i mean if you give a
man a thousand dollars you feed him for
a day but you teach a man to make a
thousand dollars and you feed him
so then why do you need the money
at this point i'm not working as well so
my bills are
my husband was able to pay them but
they're coming up again and we may end
up homeless
how long have you haven't you had a job
since september
we're in october yeah it's been 30 days
how will you decide who goes off we
should write something down put it in a
pot and then maybe one of somebody else
can read it like i'll read it let's go
sorry joe you gotta go sorry joe are you
guys ready for the second round
yeah yes all right we've started oh do
you think
abby you should go next because
i know i'm going next so i just want to
say something why do you think that he
was you're going next yeah she could be
going
because everybody stood up and said abby
i think you should go next abby the girl
that girl
she's like you know what i don't even
want to do this this ain't even fun
it's dumb yeah and the one in the middle
is like really not liking it either
i get you need money but are you gonna
be so shameless that you're gonna act
like that on
on a video yeah and abby's just like
okay your knowledge you're gonna be that
shameless now you gotta go
yeah you don't believe in yourself so
here's what i think is interesting
though
i've heard that i'm white so i can't
understand
issues or i've never said that i've
never said that i've heard white come
out she's white often
it's my turn to talk let me talk yes yes
yes yes
god damn she's not such a good person
climate change let me interrupt you
while you talk so i just think it's
interesting
that race coming from me
towards any one of you would be ghastly
and inappropriate
but race coming towards any one of you
towards me is appropriate and
please don't put me in that because i've
never said anything about race and i'm
not
saying that's appropriate because you
have the privilege to be a white person
in america
why did you just make that assumption
one and two why did you just dismiss
her experience and then marginalize her
oddly enough like yeah she's wide
passing cool great
but the fact that you centered around
this whole discussion like you know what
take it away go ahead go ahead cuz i
can't do this let me break it down i
can't do it
no i'm gonna do it i can't i'm gonna do
it i'm gonna need you to do it i'm gonna
do it if you were in a group all right
it was a couple of my white friends
and it was abba and me i gotta admit
out of all my white friends and my black
friends i am probably the most
privileged
i i went through some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
both my parents are
still together while i was living with
them i never went i never
lived in an apartment block my parents
owned buildings and stuff like that like
i'm probably the most privileged out of
that
group i'm black mind you all the thing
that my parents have
they didn't have it because of their
hard work and everything and stuff i
understand that but me coming from that
i am the most privileged as a matter of
fact we got a group
we're about seven months in that group
abba me
the rest of the people in that group
i'm probably the most privileged with
the most privilege
growing up you put any one of my white
friends they were poor poor
poor we used to go to the same school so
whenever
i was chilling at day houses i had to go
to the projects where they live white
folks
afghani latinos i was probably the most
privileged one
i'm not a rich kid but because they were
so
unprivileged i was known as the rich kid
so to assume it's like a
misunderstanding of what white privilege
is
why privilege is saying that all the
burdens that you have
are not because of your
skin color but it doesn't mean that she
cannot be poor it doesn't mean that she
cannot
not have pills not not be discriminated
it doesn't mean none of that
it just means that all the burdens you
had
it was not it didn't happen because of
the skin tone
the skin tone that you have you want to
hear irony the black man was dismissed
because he was told it was black now
he's dismissing other people because
they're white yeah and he thinks that
makes
things right yeah because he was
dismissed so he can dismiss yeah that
does not solve the issue let me just say
this
i think i get why people have some of
this rhetoric but
also understand like the most important
division between us as people is not
race but it's
class i have more in common
with a poor hispanic or power white dude
from my neighborhood
than i do with a rich black person who
grew up in a suburb area
that's just how it is you'll realize in
life and you guys are gonna
eventually if you haven't already you're
gonna see this that people identify more
with their tax bracket
than they often do with their skin tone
that's why people like yeah i vote this
way one way then they get into a certain
tax bracket they start voting
differently
their allegiances and their interests
completely change somebody misguessed
your race that somebody misguessed your
gender you're going to speak up about it
correct
well no because i felt attacked in that
situation and i was hearing you saying
you don't know what i'm talking about
because of the color of your skin
oh [ __ ] you guys why are you crying
i'm trying to feel bad for everyone i'm
at this point where i want to stick
around
in the match so i can be actively in the
discussion but i'm like starting to hear
everyone's
input and i'm like like oh
shoot like maybe i don't deserve this
you know i'm like [ __ ]
were you forfeiting and if i think it's
the eyeless you go home please raise
your hand
this is why are you still gone
she literally said like i don't know if
i deserve this oh
that's what she said all right can we
just fast forward to the part where they
eliminate all the white people
yeah if i don't get a break i genuinely
don't know what's gonna happen to me
that's everybody though you guys were
talking about like having like
guaranteed futures and careers and stuff
and i was just saying that like
having a kid is like that's talk about a
guaranteed thing in your future like
that
that's a guaranteed future to me you
have the child
you have to have the child and now the
child's here so you have to pay for your
child
and be responsible for it
wait wait abby was white and she
couldn't understand the issues
dude you're gay you have a husband you
can't understand the issues of putting
someone to life i'm using your logic i
don't even agree with what i'm saying
i'm using your logic that is your logic
abby's white she doesn't understand the
issues of black people
and brown people and whatever whatever
but you
can't have kids so you sh
according to what you're saying oh it's
a tie
i think they should do a tiebreaker
amongst themselves like sudden death
how about they decide sure that is not
fair
we gotta figure something out we can
take some input i don't think that they
should be able to vote but i think that
they should be able to give you you want
to
okay because they're they're objective
i don't think that's gonna be fair
because every single one of them before
they got out voted for me
so what are they gonna say yeah how do
you how do you possibly know that um i
saw you write my name down wrong
you voted because you wrote the thing
wrong and i'm
you just look like you assumed about me
you feel bad about me can we can we
can you give us a second can we pause
i'm sorry can we really pause i really
don't need you to antagonize me why
don't you just
be quiet i have been okay then keep
going back to that
i am a good person i am a good person
i'm a good person i'm such a good person
and then you just dismiss everyone else
you make assumptions about everyone who
was there
and then when they make bruh
whoo
i think this is easily like the most
dislikable video
you know what you know what i just
realized what you would you just
realized
they're worse than soho karen
in a way explain that one to me so who
karen
just has zero self-awareness
you saw her parents fair she was born
into that
these people fame being woke they
pretend to
understand others they demand empathy
so karen doesn't give a sh gail this is
what i am
[ __ ] in a way they're worth
soho karen born this way potato
it's over for her that's she that's all
she knows she's her the way her mom
raised her bro
all she knows these people pretend to be
woke
there's a little bit more of an evilness
to it do you understand why
bro did you see my face that is a
hundred
they are actually the last person that's
gonna say
is the worst person and the first person
that got is the least
worst person in a way and what's also
interesting is like so karen everyone
can look at her and like she's terrible
these people create a bit of confusion
yes because they
they they hide behind the group yeah
they oh i'm gonna hide behind black
people to tell you
be silent you don't have a right to
speak as a
man i'm gonna hide behind this to be
able to tell you you as a single mother
it's your problem you see what i'm
saying
i don't know maybe maybe i'm wrong no no
no no no no i'm gonna just say
maybe but like i remember watching soho
karen and
for me there was a part of me that it's
like you know what it's like it's like
when you see a fat person
like a fat child and you try to be like
oh is there parents
their parents are feeding them like
crazy and the parents obese so they
inherit that
and then when they get older it's super
hard to lose it you feel what i'm saying
i understand there's a little bit of
sadness that comes in
even if i say hold her accountable she
touched that kid whatever
there's a little bit of sadness in me
knowing like those parents mess those
kids up
yeah these people i can't say one way or
the other but because
they pretend to be one way it's why it
annoys me
you know those people who who pretend to
be like
for a cause and they'll be like all this
and then you find out later like oh they
engaged in that same stuff you mean
amber heard
just call her out just say her name say
her name say her name
when everyone's around her they act
certain way though
all right so raise your hand if you vote
for cat
whatever all right final round you have
to unanimously
decide who's the one person who leaves
with a thousand dollars
did you guys make a final decision yeah
what'd you guys decide
we decided on shakira yeah we picked
shakira because
they had already decided prior and i
said he's leaving the money on the table
right so i'll give him something could
use it all right
this has been nothing but sadness
and arguing and conflict and hurt
feelings
and i'm happy with the decision because
i am in a dire need for it i just i am
very thankful for the decision that they
made and
you know how everything played out and
now i'm excited i'm happy
crazy bro
dumpster fire in a car crash
in a train wreck
but it really shows you people
oh man people are shocked the way joe
got shut down and he can't talk
wow that's all i got i just
just ugh i mean compared to soho karen
these people left a way worse taste of
my mouth i don't know what it is
maybe other people can film the blanks
but they were just nasty
just oh they're nasty
that's all i got
[Music]
[Applause]
day
[Music]
and